you tuber rivers eat the dead bees I
forgot my name
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen today we're back for
another what I you to date youtuber
review and I've gotten a lot of requests
for you guys to review some kind of
Fitness youtubers so today we're gonna
be reviewing fit in with cambree so
Cambria is a fitness Instagrammer
youtuber blogger actor
she is also really made a splash on
YouTube and Instagram with her meal
plans
she teaches fitness classes she even
offers Skype calls and classes to help
you get the Beachbody you deserve
there's a lot to unpack here folks so
let's get to it past seven or eight pm
and I push my breakfast off a little bit
later if I eat if I stop eating at like
6:00 or 7:00 in the night wake up and
eat right away click hungry so I always
adjust my meal I breakfast based on how
late I ate dinner the night before so
that's a great tip for leaning out brain
shot is making sure you're giving
yourself enough time without so let's
unpack that one of the big claims of
intermittent fasting is that we burn
more fat particularly if we are doing
kind of cardio in a fasted state often
called fasted state cardio so kind of
research suggests that working out in a
fasted state may have some mild fat
burning potential but it also means you
could kind of blow through your glycogen
stores and then start burning into your
metabolically active muscle which would
not be good for your metabolism or for
fat burning potential so weight loss may
happen when it comes to intermittent
fasting partially because fewer eating
episodes means less insulin and insulin
is a fat storage hormone but also just
because fewer eating episodes and less
time eating means less calories in fact
a review found that intermittent fasting
was no more effective when it comes to
weight loss than just continuous caloric
restriction like most diets however
evidence suggests that we might
lose a few pounds but we also will
likely gain them all back in fact one
study found that fasting me trigger
binge eating episodes because it throws
off our sensitivity for hunger and
satiety cues and also it may kind of
trigger us to overdo it when we finally
do eat just out of desperation and
hunger the study found that these non
fasting days led people to kind of
totally overeat and overdo it and while
we don't have a lot of long-term
research on intermittent fasting it's
very possible that these binge like
tendencies could have the potential to
actually cause weight gain over time I
have an entire video on intrument
fasting so you can check that out right
here bottom line there's definitely some
clinical applications when it comes to
intermittent fasting for things like
diabetes or heart disease in clinical
kind of supervised conditions and I'm
really keeping an eye on the research
because it's absolutely evolving so I'm
definitely keeping an open mind however
I do not think that interim fasting is
the magic pill for sustainable weight
loss okay so it looks like it is workout
time with her friend Erica Costello so
let's take a look
[Applause]
Alex Hart that looks like a great
workout but one thing I want to kind of
flag is that I looked everywhere to find
out what cambree's fitness credentials
were or her nutrition credentials and of
course I came up blank so if any of you
guys have heard of cambree's credentials
maybe she mentions them in another video
that I missed please let me know but
until then I'm gonna take these tips
with a grain of salt so instead of a
focus in this workout on gaining
strength and feeling good they're using
a lot of triggering words like kind of
toning and leaning out to get your beach
bod great for your waist and ultimately
just trying to focus on getting those
summer abs when really any fitness
professional will make it very clear
that we cannot spot train our body we
likely cannot get a tinier waist without
also getting like losing our boobs and
our ass so I also don't love how kind of
working out with these girls is really
just all about getting that summer body
and not about improving health and not
about improving strength let's look at
the breakfast and then vanilla protein
also another fun trick is adding pitted
dates which they're pitted some rather
than the enemy saying they're getting
hard chunks in their shapes and it's
closing it the dates I joined everything
and then and then literally all I do is
almond milk to this coconut water is
also delicious trick in summertime to
make it a little more fruity but I don't
have any with me
Wow she is a smoothie expert she knows
exactly how much liquid to include I
love it okay so smoothies I mean I'm not
against smoothies I think they're in a
convenient way to get your your
post-workout snack in first of all I
want to kind of just mention that her
breakfast is at 11:30 which by that time
I've already had like three meals but I
mean to each their own again I know it's
the intrument fasting thing going on
probably nothing I could ever do now in
terms of her shake I guess like this is
a really nice balanced option she's got
some protein from
protein powder she's got carbohydrates
from the dates and the almond milk and
the and the fruit in there so that's
great
and you know don't fear carbs especially
after a workout I think a lot of people
think that after workout they just need
protein no not true they're simple
sugars in like some of those
carbohydrates like the dates or the
mango can help to kind of elicit a
little bit of an insulin response which
helps drive the protein into the muscle
faster to aid in recovery so having a
post-workout snack that has that nice
combination of carbohydrates and protein
is a really great place to be now I have
no issues with protein powder it's
definitely convenient source of protein
and I'm not speaking directly about her
protein powder however the whole
industry in general is not very well
regulated especially with some of these
smaller companies so a lot of them have
been shown to contain contaminants and
also become like stuffed with fillers
and cheaper ingredients in fact study
conducted by the clean label project
found that they tested 134 different
protein powders and 74% of them
contained contaminants they also on
their website rate all the protein
powders with kind of like a score so to
let you know the best ones to buy
another way to trust a protein powder is
to look for the National Sanitation
Foundation's certified sport which means
that it's being tested for contaminants
and substances my bottom line when it
comes to protein powders is yes they're
convenient but I also think that there's
other kind of whole food ways to get
just as high quality protein so when it
comes to smoothies sometimes I like to
add plain Greek yogurt nut butter hemp
arts soft tofu or cause cheese I also
want to talk about her Green Goddess
powder so basically this looks like a
bunch of kind of veggie extracts and
some enzymes and caffeine in there and
it's you know Green powders are fine for
people who don't get a lot of fruits and
vegetables in their diet but to add this
to a smoothie that already has a ton of
fruit seems like overkill and a waste of
money to me also the only nutrients that
the nutrition label lists are things
like vitamin C and carbohydrates and
she's already getting a ton of vitamin C
from the mango and the blueberries and
carbohydrates from the fruit and the
dates in the almond milk
so you know if you're worried about
vegetables just throw in a handful
spinach you're gonna get the fiber and
you can save yourself 50 bucks I'm also
so happy to see that Cambria is not on
board with the food combining trend
because I just do not have the energy
for another food combining rant right
now now before we get into the next meal
I want to take a detour and listen to
what she has to say about getting in
your Beachbody House it's a gorgeous day
it's 100 degrees in this Pride weekend
so we need to go lay out in the Sun I
know celebrate having our Sun our bods
I've worked all year to feel confident
and so it's really great to work so hard
and then feel confident when you're in
bikini with your friends I know how it
feels to feel insecure in a bathing suit
it's I still do but definitely taking
care of yourself and feeling ready at
all times is one of the best frame
feelings at the woman being like knowing
you took care take care of yourself and
your bodies as healthy as it can be like
you want to just feel free in a bathing
suit so I'm feel free okay so it's great
that cambrie like feels confident in a
bathing suit and wants to feel free and
all that stuff I love that but what I'm
not loving is this kind of summer bod
bikini bod I worked so hard for this bod
I should you know celebrate it rhetoric
so many women go through painstaking
steps to achieve that summer bod and
it's so easily can like lead down into
disorderly territory we need to change
the conversation and the goals we can do
better than this so cambree herself
talks about how she often feels insecure
in her bathing suit which i think is a
very relatable statement to make however
I can imagine that is very triggering
for a lot of people who are watching
this because the the statement and and
the suggestion is that she earned that
confidence she earned it by working for
that summer bought all year long but
confidence is not something that needs
to be earned through hard work in the
gym or in the kitchen confidence should
be just a byproduct of living your
healthiest happiest most intuitive life
a bikini body is just a body in a bikini
and we need to get over this consumerism
drip
concept and I really would love if
cambree would get on board she driving
and and talking and shooting at the same
time her mind just like totally going
crazy right now
[Music]
okay so I think this is just like a bit
of a montage of you know cambrie and her
sister modeling and I love it like I
love the confidence amazing you you feel
like girl I just don't have time for
this so we're gonna skip ahead to snack
time let's see the food where's the food
at love chocolate-covered almonds can't
go wrong with anything chocolate-covered
I'm pretty sure but yeah it's a pretty
like healthier kind of more nutritious
treat we've got some protein and some
fiber some healthy fats and iron what's
not to love all right so quick snacky
snack over let's talk about what's for
lunch I'm getting hungry
that looks so good
well that looks like an amazing plate
that I just want to dig into but she's
got lots of stuff going on some protein
in there from the meat she's got some
healthy fats from avocado we've got some
veggies little low on the carbs I mean
she only had like a couple tortilla
chips she could have easily thrown all
those goodies into like one of those
corn tortillas and made like an actual
taco but regardless I think it's a
really healthy balanced delicious fresh
looking meal so well done cambrie all
right we're getting ready for dinner and
we're gonna have a little snack a little
pre-dinner snack
[Music]
I totally agree I also love Anna mommy I
think that they're such an easy kind of
snack that you can take on the go that
come in their own little package it's
like fantastic we've got the fiber we've
got the protein I also could snack on
edamame all day long and I think that's
soy gets a really bad reputation
unnecessarily so I've done a whole video
on soy protein and the myths and the
misconceptions and you can check it out
right here however I don't love her use
of the word clean here no I mean what
does that even mean like if you wash
your food it's clean that's that's my
interpretation of the word clean so
hopefully we can all start using it in
the proper way moving forward cambrie
I'm looking at you alright so let's move
on to dinner we're starting with some
butter one great option - I ran out of
it but you guys only use Kerrygold
peanuts grass-fed it's your body can
process it better
okay so just quickly gonna talk about
the grass-fed butter here because she's
claiming that your body can process it
better basically kind of digest it
better grass-fed butter is produced by
cows who are fed grass makes sense
whereas conventional cows are usually
fed a corn or green based diet there's
no research to suggest that either
butter is digested or processed better
than the other however we do know that
grass-fed butter might be slightly more
nutritious for us so research has found
that grass-fed butter may be higher in
omega threes have more conjugated
linoleic acid CLA vitamin k2 as well as
beta carotene bottom line I mean they're
both fats so they're digested the exact
same because the body is gonna kind of
elicit the same digestive enzymes to
break it down so I wouldn't be choosing
one over the other for processing or
digestion purposes but personally I like
the flavor of grass-fed butter
or it is a bit of a luxury it's more
expensive which ever you choose I would
say use it in moderation and use it in a
way that kind of adds and flavors your
food alright let's see some more of the
dinner let this all sit here for like
five minutes then we take five seconds
this meal I love to judge because quick
and also with you guys drink somewhere
try to make meals with friends try to
eat at home so I always thought garlic
salt and pepper on everything so I'm
going to add that to everything so first
of all I just want to say that I love
love love that Camry talks about eating
as a like friends and family cooking
together eating more often at home these
are amazing tips that really have
nothing to do with kind of weight loss
and I really appreciate that I also love
that she's talking about making food
accessible and easy and quick and
realistic her meal here is nothing fancy
she talks about going to Trader Joe's
loved Trader Joe's one of my like
biggest regrets of being a Canadian is
that we don't have Trader Joe's here but
I agree it's so convenient and they've
got so many great options and I love
that she's literally making all of this
in one pan it's not fancy it's not
Instagram a bowl but it's real and I
love that so let's take a look at her
nutrition for the day cambrie's daily
caloric intake is around 1920 calories
the percentage of her diet from carbs is
about 39% from protein it's 21% and from
fats it's 40% okay so when it comes to
the macros I mean these are a pretty
average I think for what's in vogue
right now a little bit lower carbs a
little bit higher fat nothing I'm really
concerned about the only thing that I
would definitely flag is that there
wasn't really enough vitamin D every day
but that's very common when it comes to
getting vitamin D from your diet so my
only hope is that she's taking a
supplement that she just isn't really
referencing or talking about
now let's talk about what I like about
cambree's day first of all she eats
well-balanced meals and snacks for the
most part I would say that I'm really
impressed that Camry makes a point to
combine protein with carbohydrates to
ensure that she's having a really
satisfying meal and also with the
exception of course of the morning
because of the intrument fasting she is
eating fairly regularly it seems like
every two to three hours or so she's
having something to eat so I think that
is kind of a good place for a lot of
people to be number two I think her
meals are really accessible and easy for
people she talks a lot about using
shortcuts like Trader Joe's meals which
i think is great she talks about kind of
cooking together and making it fun
making it easy
none of those meals seem overly kind of
time-consuming or require a lot of fancy
ingredients with the exception of course
of the supplements that she sells but I
do think that you know that these are
things that people you know regardless
of how much experience you have in the
kitchen you could probably pull this off
and number three there aren't too many
restrictions I mean yes she's following
intermón fasting I also don't think she
eats dairy or gluten but other than that
she's not really encouraging people to
cut out full food groups and she's
enjoying a variety of different kinds of
foods so in terms of the kind of online
fitness world I guess that's pretty good
now I want to talk about what I don't
like unfortunately it's a lot first of
all all of the toxic diet culture
language throughout the video Kamri says
clean eating like five times and she
talks at nauseam about how to get your
perfect beach body and how you can be
proud of your beach body when you've
really invested a lot of time and effort
into it I've said it earlier and I'll
say it again this just fuels toxic dye
culture in this young generation and it
really needs to stop if you are on a
beach and in a bikini Congrats
you have a beach bikini body number two
where's the credibility you can go
online and you can book a 30-minute
session with cambree spend a hundred
dollars to get nutrition and fitness
advice from an unregulated professional
I looked at
and I wasn't able to find anything about
her credentials but I was able to find a
festival detox yes there's a meal plan
to get your body ready for Coachella at
the beginning of the meal plan she
includes a disclaimer which is awesome
and really should be included in all of
her YouTube videos and this is a great
start but I'm actually way more
concerned about what is in the meal plan
itself so her tips for success are
basically just a strict set of rules
drink lots of water okay that would make
sense no dairy no gluten no refined
processed sugar stop eating before 7:00
work out extremely hard sauna three
times weekly if possible stick to a
timed eating schedule and my favorite
listen to your body this one seems to
contradict all of the other ones because
yes not eating when you're hungry
cutting out your favorite foods
exercising to the point of exhaustion
are all things that you would
intuitively do when you're listening and
loving and appreciating your body not so
much people need to stop co-opting
intuitive eating language into diet
culture I'm not falling for it and you
really shouldn't either anyway the rest
of the meal plan is basically just her
in a bikini promoting her supplements
which are essential for detoxing on the
meal plan so yeah she's not a dietitian
but she's a pretty good entrepreneur so
I will give her props for that
finally the meal plan gets into the
actual meals and based on some rough
calculations I discovered that the
calories are extremely low day one
barely reaches 1,500 calories and I find
it really hard to believe that anyone's
gonna be able to sustain an extremely
hard workout working with that little
fuel in the tank I do like the morning
affirmations but that is about the only
thing I like about this meal plan okay
enough about that
so in conclusion cambrie's diet is
actually pretty well balanced it's it's
certainly not bad I think it's it's got
lots of great ideas here that are very
accessible and easy however her
contribution to diet culture and the
wellness diet leaves a lot to be desired
she promotes her products as
taxes and essential for getting a summer
bod promoting and selling supplements
without really any credentials attached
to her name what I want my viewers to
walk away with here is that health of
course is an investment it often takes
energy it takes time and sometimes it
can take money so if you are reading
things or seeing things online whether
on YouTube or someone's blog or website
and they're asking you to kind of invest
financially in their version of health I
want you to kind of do a deep dive and
think about what is the lifestyle that
they're promoting what is the verbiage
that they're using and are you aligned
with it and maybe most importantly what
are their credentials or lack thereof
also I think I've emphasized this enough
but I just have to say again the summer
festival beach body bull detox is clean
eating this is not intuitive and this is
not sustainable and this is not the road
to achieving optimal health eat what
feels good to you go to a festival put
on the bikini go lay on a beach and
enjoy your blessed life so guys I hope
you enjoyed this video if you did be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below with some other youtubers
you want me to review subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]